I can tell you that I feel this
excitement and creativity around the new
technologies in biology like it was
Silicon Valley 78 years ago I do like I
remember having really fun geek outs
when I was there but I tell my gosh like
we could use you know aw like Amazon Web
Services just came out like we can use
this and train a big network and then we
can you know solve this and they'll make
a company like people felt that now the
conversations I have here are the same
thing people like wait a second you can
use CRISPR to knock down this
transcription oh my god you've solved
the disease like that's really and then
people just like start piecing together
these different parts and so if there's
one thing that like is important to get
people excited about is that shift of
biology is now this engineering
substrate not just like a descriptive
thing boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sockin we
are still at MIT in Cambridge in
Massachusetts we are at the brain and
cognitive sciences building we are going
to be talking about developing
technologies to capture the complexity
of biology the brain and so much more we
have Daniel Goodwin joining us on the
show hello dude thrilled to be here
thank you so much for coming on I'm
super excited and he shout out to out of
marble stone Alex K Chen for making
these introductions happen good people
good people for sure Daniel Goodwin is a
PhD student at MIT Media Lab making
technologies to explore the brain
previously he was an entrepreneur
co-founder of my like you and
entrepreneur and residents at IDEO and
you can find his website link Daniel are
good wyndcomm as well as his LinkedIn
profile in the bio are a damn let's
start things off with our question that
we love asking we find ourselves as
stewards of earth what is your current
take on the state of humanity oh man
start on the small questions huh I have
to answer that in from three different
perspectives and so I guess we get
through this conversation it's gonna
come up like I there's different ways of
viewing the same thing so I'm gonna
start with the perspective of the
designer and the designer starts with
the empathy first for the individual and
when I say is likely then that says like
everyone's beautiful everyone's got a
story so the story of humanity right now
from that perspective is that a lot of
things are changing people are concerned
you know so but Humanity is beautiful
I'm mending in us contrast that with the
perspective of somebody that in his
career has bought hundreds of
thousands of dollars of ads online and
that gives me this perspective this a
little darker where I think about the
social media and I think about the
persuasion machines because I really
think that's the right term for those
things and when you think of it that way
the the future of humanity is scary
because we have these new technologies
and I've seen those things work I was
one of the first people to buy Facebook
Ads all the way back in 2010 and at the
beginning then we were amazed by how
good they were and there's a reason
those things doubled in price every year
2010 2011 2012 all the way like 2016 so
anyway from the persuasions machine side
I think there's a technologies that are
very scary and the only way to really
fight against that I think is to improve
our education improve our minds and so
that's why I love what you're doing the
third perspective is the scientist of
what I do now and the scientist what I
do now is I work with technologies to
build change biology we're both
exploring biology for them as we go into
it we realize that as we find these new
things we can repurpose them and we can
use those to fight disease to explore
the brain deeper to explore other organs
to start doing multi scale Maps and so
from that perspective I'm extremely
excited because I think that what we're
sitting on now is kind of very analogous
to kind of where we wear with with
electronics forty years ago what we're
doing now with the can be able to
recombine all these different biological
tools to start building applications on
top of that oh man it's a very very
exciting time for Humanity in terms of
the technologies and biology that are
gonna come out yes yes well those three
perspectives they're the designer the
persuasive technologists and then the
one that's actually building the
technologies to better understand the
body and give us the tools to increase
our longevity our like working memory or
intelligence augment
eradicate disease meant ourselves yeah
your radar it's so funny because you'll
end up explaining this but you thanks to
a lot of mentors and other influencers
you've been able to align yourself with
that higher purpose and meaning to
pursue what you're doing now and I'm
excited to be able to get into that yeah
there's a really great quote that I
heard recently which is that too the
goal is to fall in love with a problem
that it's not a technology and so if
you've got and I love that there's a
bunch of different ways to slice it
there's a really good read which is a
man's search for meaning
and he what he says all the time is he
quotes Nietzsche who says like that if
you have a good y-you can survive anyhow
and it's it's a great idea and it's the
same thing like when you've got a battle
flag that people can get behind sorry
it's it's night and day
yeah and so yeah I mean finding build it
using biology to make humans better is
one of the most inspiring things yes but
now but you also need to start diving in
that even further right yeah I want to
make the world a better place doesn't
mean much right I want to understand the
brain to cure disease that's there and
then if you can go even one step further
then like then you start getting into a
tangible problem yes and being
technology agnostic as you tackle that
problem it's critical and because
there's always gonna be new frontiers
and technology push to be able to tackle
them yeah we need to adapt and yeah and
that's one of the things I'm really
excited to chat with you too because
I've noticed that a lot of the biggest
technologies that end up coming out
started as a sub problem of the sub
problem and you look at Google right
Google was structuring information in
the digital library initiative from NSF
right that was a so problem of a sub
problem and by the way for any kids
listening out there do your linear
algebra homework because PageRank is
just an eigenvalue problem anyway
PageRank is a pagan PageRank is like
actually a very simple linear algebra so
linear I mean it's brilliant but like
the point is yeah like anyway I thought
that is getting hugely tangential but
the idea is being exposed to what the
valuable subproblems are yeah and so to
think about these huge things to totally
change our life if you trace back their
lineage they start as a sub problem of a
sub problem turns out was really big
CRISPR you just talked to George Church
is the same idea and some was like
programmable nucleic acid editing right
who would have thought that was
important well biologists would have
thought that is important but the
average person on the street ten years
ago would if I that would have meant
nothing to write Oh like we already know
things had key like can cut DNA that's
not important oh but if we can make it
programmable anybody can use it to cut
anything next thing you know you're
solving monogenic diseases you're so
you're giving kids like us solving forms
of blindness you know solving forms of
solving sickle cell anemia like there's
these very interesting applications that
are coming from what originally was a
subproblem of a subproblem and ssun it's
the family members themselves that say
that my child might
errant my relative got there fix is now
saying the phrase crisper right yeah the
scientists yeah where can I put more
money into it yeah so and that's what I
love so much is like you know from my
journey and as a PhD student is to be
exposed to these subproblems of
subproblems
the things that I get most excited about
now I never even would have would have
known or a problem or I never would have
known were a challenge when I started
this PhD four years ago I thought that
it was gonna be taking machine learning
algorithms and and and processing image
data and then that was was going to be
to solve the brain four years later and
we can hoppin around here I love it I
think it'd be helpful to tell you that
the narrative and in chronological order
yeah but the punchline at least where
I'm at now is what I find myself being
so excited about now are things that
wouldn't even known were an issue before
you know before I started doing this and
I think that's also one of the things
that I can sell something here it's to
get people excited about biology yeah
because when I took biology in high
school it was just it was a descriptive
science yeah right like we had to study
and like memorize all the different like
things and and who cares about it but
now I see biology as an engineer MMH
biology as an engineer is no longer a
descriptive science it's a physical
science with applications that are super
wide-ranging and that is really fun damn
that is a profound pivot in yeah it is
yeah it's no longer just labeling the
cell but it's now become a I'm applying
this as an engineer across the world in
agriculture in healthcare in xfield Y
field it's just endless where the
applications are so this is it's only
the beginning of whatever's quoted to be
a hundred trillion dollar industry over
the next hundred years or something
crazy like that so yeah yeah so well
yeah that that means there's a lot of
entrepreneurship and a lot of creative
potential to be explored in the field
let's do the journey
ok so you've had a crazy journey born in
the Bay Area then raised in Idaho and
then down in LA for college and then up
to Stanford for brain computer
interfaces teach us about this
trajectory yeah so work on the brain now
my undergrad was I set off bombs on
bridges
whoa yeah so it's been a journey how do
we to rebuild it no to characterize them
so an actually simulation lies no no we
actually set off they call them cold gas
thrusters we went out to remote bridges
in Maine and we set off these things and
they create these impulses throughout
the structure and we put these really
high-resolution accelerometers all
throughout the structure and you can
characterize it and there's a and then
you can characterize the resonant
frequency these bridges and that gives
you an idea of like if a terrorist was
to place a bomb here you know where
would the weak point be anyway so from
that yeah it was really fun professor
Jerome at Harvey Mudd College was my
mentor he was phenomenal so how did I go
from that to the brain well the thing
that they get the all of that research
was signal processing right so we got
all these accelerometers on a bridge we
use those to create a model of the
bridge well in some ways that's similar
to the way I thought of the brain
initially right we take electrodes we
can put them in the brain we can measure
high resolution electrical activity and
then we could decode that to move robots
and that was my dream and so I went to I
shall says also when I started getting
involved with entrepreneurial activity
so the end of the end of college started
doing some web stuff but really my goal
was to like to become a neuroscientist
so I enrolled at Stanford as a PhD
student Electrical Engineering and my I
got talking to a person in a lab that
was doing these brain computer
interfaces using the robots and that the
mode there and it still kind of is the
way it works is that you put these
electrodes in an animal and then you
create a machine learning algorithm to
learn what those active that activity is
in order to articulate you know like the
the degrees of freedom of a robotic arm
and then I remember I had this very
clear moment where I was a I was
first-year grad student super wide-eyed
and I met this guy in the hallway or was
like the social and he was working this
lab but I really really wanted to work
in and I just said wow this is me like I
really want to work in this stuff and he
looks at me so sad and he's just like
I've spent four years training an
algorithm on one animal and the animal
died and and take another four years to
retrain the the algorithm to do the
robotic task it was doing and I remember
this because I remember see feeling so
shocked and so sad for him
and that's what realize like okay like
that would that created my first crisis
of confidence in neuroscience where I
was like okay it's clearly there's got
to be a better way
I don't want electrodes shoved in my
brain you know the exceptions are for
people that you know are locked in or
have like a severe spinal cord injury
there was no way to translate the data
translated to another animal knotted
that now this was ten years ago
like and all those people that work in
those fields are like are fantastic I'm
sure they've solved it but like the
state of the art at that point that it
was pretty much like one animal one
algorithm yeah Wow so that's when I took
a step back okay well what really is the
problem here like is the problem
electrodes in the brain er is the
problem the data processing and also at
this point like I was just I was a
20-something dude right like I was in
the middle of Silicon Valley the mobile
like wave is taking off and I realized
that you know the data processing is the
biggest challenge just across the board
so another fantastic mentor of mine so I
got to work with Fei Fei Lee superstar
and really nice person and so I worked
in her lab for a while and we were doing
natural scene recognition natural scene
recognition being like is this a photo
of a classroom is this a photo of the
woods the funny thing about this is this
is right before the Alex net came out
right before the phrase deep learning
really just like hockey stick so we were
working on things before the deep
learning what craves so in fact like
everything I worked on then was pretty
much just wiped out by the Hinton's work
and yeah the neural networks work but
the amazing thing about that was to
start doing image processing and then
that's when I realized that you know
like this is when iPhones have read been
out for about two years so the idea of
like all this data coming out in the
world and the need to process it was
like this was this isn't like that this
like a really a good big inflection
point and I fell in love with that the
data processing side so the first thing
I did was I did fMRI analysis thinking
that would be an interesting way to
study the brain so to say this is so
critical because it's something around
90% of all data is created is a good
create in the last two years just keeps
keeps happening with the IOT era and
with all the brain mapping that we're
doing the biology mapping it's just oh
yeah we need to be able to process this
data in coherent ways that can be passed
down to the gen C and passed I regularly
talk about terabyte data sets
I will use terabyte data sets and like
I'm 33 years old so I started life with
the flow of the three and a half inch
poppy so it's crazy to be thinking about
you know like a room built yeah exactly
okay come right so anyway I was doing
the image and processing analysis but
what I realized is that the deeper I
went in the image and I hiked out of a
data processing side the further away I
was getting from touching people and the
thing is like I think an important part
about my background is my mom's a nurse
my dad's a professor yeah and I really
liked and I kind of have that
perspective of like I want to work on
our problems but it's got to be rooted
in people yes you know and so I found
myself drifting you know like just
chasing harder and harder problems mmm
but then kind of getting lost on like
what them what my battle flag was and I
got really lucky by enrolling in a class
of the Stanford Design School and it's
my complete fluke that I even got in it
really should be like I should not take
any credit for this I was dating a girl
at the time and she's like I really want
to take this class it was called from
play to innovation and it was taught by
Stuart brown and Brendan Boyle amazing
Stuart brown by the way is the guy who
coined the idea of play as a primal need
yeah his wall it's such good work and
then Brendan Boyle right like is a
partner at IDEO and he's um it teaches
the D school and we didn't get to guys
show yeah oh my god yes from play to
from played innovation to innovation and
in beautiful yeah and it was the perfect
time for where I was in life because I
had now like wandered down like I can I
kind of wandered into the dark searching
for hard computational problems and I
was distant from like the why I do it
when you go into the Stanford Design
School in the ideal way of thinking the
first thing you ask is who are we trying
to touch you know and then why you know
was like what's their problem what are
their needs then how can we solve it the
very last thing you get to is like what
is the technology we actually need
before you can get to that you've
already prototype things you can fake
you've got some confidence and that's
what you need to build and then you'd
like do the hard part of the technology
and for me like I can't tell you what a
180 that was and that's also when I
realized like oh man I'm not made for
the PhD right now and so that you know
once again like trying to figure things
out and I had this like big moment of
like okay I want to like I want to
recenter on people and so Brendan Boyle
at IDEO gave me the great opportunities
like look I do is we have a role for
entrepreneurs
you've got some background in mobile and
mobile apps at that point I spent a
summer working with a friend of the
business school created a company called
pocket gems which is now a gigantic
mobile gaming superstar company whoa
and so I got to so I spent some time in
startups
I'd already like when I said like I
bought Facebook Ads like this is what I
bought Facebook Ads yeah and that was
the start of that and realizing like
whoa you know like either people are
quite model when it comes to like
getting people to click on things that's
like that's kind of like one night when
I say things that are cynical it's based
on on our model abble to get them to
click on things yeah you know so it's
like that where our epics my world I get
it I feel this and like yeah but that's
usually I felt that and then that the
fact that you've tapped in yeah deal
yeah and talk to people about it versus
just doing it without recalibrating and
thinking yeah yeah yeah that's huge so
the conversation I had with idea was
that they were interested in mobile apps
they were interested in trying to
explore things outside you know like the
the fee-for-service it's like how can we
think like idea who's got such a great
background I should describe Who I do is
because I'm just I'm throwing around
this buzzword and for me it's been such
an important part of who I am but it is
just you know it's a name so I yeah I'm
such a good yeah fantastic place been
around for 30 or 40 years the foundation
like founded by for people who are all
giants in their respective fields and
it's got the background of being
involved with the early days of the that
they invented the mouse they meant the
laptop there and what they preach or
what they sell is a process of solving
problems yes right like they you know
and that's kind of a really important
thing like you don't guarantee an
outcome you guarantee doing a process as
well as you can yeah and so their whole
thing is called a human centered design
process and that starts with
understanding people prototyping towards
something that solves their problem and
then you can figure out how you want to
scale it up yeah keeping the human
focusing every human centered design
that's that's the phrase and so when we
took it would end up being nine rounds
of interviews you know it was like they
took it very seriously
yeah and so when I showed up there they
have this policy they're like look
everyone at IDEO is really in
testing and awesome and yada yada so we
don't care it's all about like welcome
to the place like what do you do first
you know like it's all about like what
credibility you can build inside the
firm and so I was coached like hey look
we have this great opportunity it fits
your background perfectly we've got this
joint venture with Sesame Street yeah
and we want to explore what it means to
do like mobile apps and specifically
like we started with this idea of potty
training yeah so now this is like a very
funny point to just plot right yeah it's
really I'm a 26 year old guy I just went
from a windowless office in the computer
science building you know where we took
a photo out of faith days office like
just to see what it might looks like and
we put it up on the wall like that's
like that was like the windowless office
when we worked in and then now like I'm
in this beautiful design firm where like
people are well dressed and well slept
and like I'm sitting on the bathroom
floor like learning about potty training
with like a parent and like you know
that two-year-old and their parent but
it was also like such a great experience
for me which is the to say that this
process works you know like we went
through this really long journey of like
we had a hypothesis we tested it
everything that I do in science is
actually like that you can map it
one-to-one and I think that's where the
human centered design process like
probably started from so the
translational applications the transit
yeah but we're not talking about like
we're not solving some part of the
spliceosome like we're solving a human
need yeah and so getting kids
potty-trained getting kids Behati train
is very Sesame Street partnership we
that's so we were prototyping ways like
you know because we yeah so there was a
partnership and we're trying to figure
out like what the best opportunity would
be and so it started with potty training
but through that process of prototyping
we realized that it actually wasn't
potty training it was the opportunity
for to use Elmo as like the good Big
Brother such well Elmo is a three year
old older brother yeah you know who sets
a good example yeah and so that's great
yeah so from that opportunity we
realized that kids just like the the the
herons sink up after yourself say that
say thank you things like that brush
your teeth teeth oh that's cute yeah so
the way in the end like we made this a
product that sounds very simple but is
based on these insights of spending
hours with kids and parents
Vasili focusing on potty training but
what we realized is it's just like
having Elmo on demand it's like the good
older brother
and yes so we made an app or kids get a
FaceTime from Elmo picking a face they
get a feistel get obese the hall from
Elmo that's exactly interesting and
almost like hey hey it's time to go
brush your teeth
Wow so yeah well that's great yeah
trusted older brother
we're so far away from neuroscience but
it's gonna get on your back it's coming
back there's a David Ewing Duncan
talking to robots is coming out soon and
he talks about human robot interactions
of the future and one of them is the
Teddy robot and and and the Teddy bot is
the trusted robot that works with the
kids in all of their kids's
developmental needs and the love and
compassion and the recommendation and
this Big Brother sense and so this is a
huge part of our future I think and I
love the idea of you know getting the
from a trusted source like an elbow is
yeah that was a very crazy transition
from the basement with 9 with the
windowless room light and not having
transformations yeah and I was living in
a garage before then I mean I'm just
every cliche rolled into one
okay that's ice so that well so this is
the idea thing and what I should say is
I you know we had to get what we did is
with with the clothes llamó stories that
I had to go through the whole Sesame
Workshop educational they like they they
take their things their work very very
seriously so like did it satisfy the
educational criteria that they set out
then I got to go to New York and
actually like be on set because we got
to like write the words and see how
they'll perform it and so anyway it was
like it was a really really great story
then I got to see it scale yeah so that
was the second app that I was involved
in that like did well right so first was
social mobile gaming then it was Elmo
calls but the goal of being an idea was
to start a company yeah right like that
that was the from from the start that
was what I was supposed to do
entrepreneur resident entrepreneur
residents found a company and so what I
was focusing on and this actually goes
back to the second perspective when we
started the state of humanity question
it's as I looked around that the way we
use the Internet
and I looked at like you know every
Google search we do is used to service
ads every interaction we have on
Facebook is used to optimize our mini
feed and then service ads so I started
being curious with like the well what
can you do to give people their own data
back
that was the design prompt actually hmm
like how can you do it can you give some
people their value back right I'm
wearing activity tracker watch and that
and so I guess there's there's a
decently long story there but I was
prototyping with different ways of just
like capturing phone you know it the
data you produced from your phone is
this like data exhaust it's just there
right and so the question was I how can
we give this back to people in
meaningful ways and so I started like
everybody does in twenty twelve building
a photo sharing app and the great thing
about being in a good creative
environment is people will tell you if
it sucks
edie you know I'm doing my PhD with
he'll tell me if I'm doing bad work yeah
when I was at IDEO and I was doing this
prototype people told me like I don't
get it why are you doing this and that's
what I met you'll be careful sometimes
people can't necessarily also see the
that's yeah it's kind of double-edged in
a sense but yeah I agree though you need
to be around people that I'll tell you
why it won't work and and be very clear
and stuff and yeah that's true yeah
that's a good point though yeah I mean
like well so this is where a lot of
people have different perspectives
Brendan Boyle has a great idea that
people are their most creative when
they're they're most comfortable and I
like that idea
I would also push on it they like I
think for me like I do some of my best
work when I'm under pressure like nice
and so I don't know if there's the right
there's the right answer for each person
but I do know that like they're you know
what I'm really doing something that's
hard
I don't want hugs right I want people to
push me and I want to be better yeah
so when I was showing this photo showing
a front feels like I don't get it I was
like thank you like cuz that's the
person I would be trying to ship this
thing to and I was talking I talked to
my mentor at the time a guy named Dan
and Dan 10 years older than me same
height same build like he's a I think of
his brain like if it was me and after 10
cups of coffee and what we were talking
about his most interesting thing in the
world that's Dan's brain he was like he
let a lot of the venture thinking at
IDEO and the way he could connect ideas
and bring people together and see 10
years ahead I mean it was just it was
just like everything you'd want from a
mentor and I showed him this mic Hey
look I did this thing it tracks you
everywhere you go you can take photos
with it and you can match and he's like
yeah I don't get it either but he said
look does this tell me how I'm moving I
was like yeah he's like could you do
this to tell me whether I'm driving or
not
and I realize the media like oh man okay
I see what we're talking about here this
is like when it when you work in the
consulting business you drive to a
different different places every time
you drive you can expense it 55 cents a
mile yeah I thought oh my gosh that's a
really good business so we will
automatically track every mile you drive
using the the phone in your pocket yeah
very very simple but business now Dan
has a great quote which is don't
complete don't confuse a clear view for
a short distance
so just cuz you had a very clear view
we're making a simple product like we
just needed to take yeah we just need to
track mileage but getting that thing out
so we blew a we left I do we started the
company just him and I oh wow
and that's what we were working on and
we you know it took us about a year and
a bit and five iterations yeah before we
could ship it and so I was the founding
CTO Dan was the founding CEO yeah dan
has a phenomenal product sense and so it
yeah we had something ready like okay we
can put in the app store he's like no
it's not good enough sure enough we did
some user testing yep not good enough
scrapped it all rebuilt the interface
anyway five times later we ship it and
immediately it starts succeeding yeah
because we had something like we we had
something based on the need we done all
the same I do user testing we had the we
had the insight gosh that's huge to be
patient and so you iterate on it and
tells a beautiful enough to actually
hockey stick up the user experience yeah
I will actually share with other people
and get people using it that way yeah
yeah and so I was living off street
burritos in the Mission of San Francisco
oh man yeah it was it was it was a tough
time and so that's actually when we got
involved with startx
so we went from a situation of being in
many different you know like in a big
vibrant environment an ideal to
basically kind of working out of our
apartments in the early days the startup
and I think it's really important like
and I love what you're doing with this
like educating people and part of like
what I like a big porn thing to say is
like I think myself is it creative right
and I've learned what it means to be on
a creative journey and a big part of the
creative journey is being depressed and
like being bummed and like feeling like
crap and working through that I think is
just part of it that's like part of
doing something it's hard so when we
first started this company and I wasn't
leaving my apartment for four days at a
time just sitting in my underwear
programming I felt like crap it was a
really hard time for me personally
and so it actually will also worked out
that startx was a few years old at that
point and they're looking for
entrepreneurs and residents and there
was my background at that point there
was Dan's background and so he went
there just a few days a week to hang out
and it was all these Stanford founders
doing these companies and a lot of them
have succeeded by the way now you know
five six years later like the success
rate is super-high
here but it was great to just like kind
of be in a community again and this is
before I you know my like you started
growing and all that so and also that's
also a good example of a creative
community I think we'll come back to
that but it's definitely worth putting
putting on aside so um the the so my
late the point is like my like you
started working very early on you know
we we we had something that people
totally got we had a product that worked
and then we're at the scaling up phase
and this is kind of a it's kind of funny
to say but you work all day on a really
hard big problem right all right we've
got something working but now we need to
make the next iteration the next
iteration and it's hard to get that
thing that makes you feel good like it's
hard to get that like instant
gratification and so for me years into
the company the two most gratifying
things for me to do was customer support
and reading neuroscience papers that was
like those were my like gifts to myself
at the end of the day and you were
teaching me the customer support was
because you could immediately get
gratification from helping okay yeah
yeah it feels good it's like hey you
know I happen to miss this drive now
look in the data's like yep I see what
happened solved it you know and thank
you so much for being customer and like
here's a perk yeah you know what I call
thank you Wow
you also see some weird cases in
customer support like you know yeah Mike
there was this one guy who was just
being so rude you know every time I'd be
like oh yes yeah like you know well like
happy to help any happy yeah is like so
rude back and then one day he just
emailed me back like weeks later he's
like look I was going through divorce
you were like the only person who is
nice to me I appreciate it it's like wow
man so yeah humanity at scale right like
the weird emails you get and you so
we're successful enough and ended up
selling to Microsoft so that happened
later yeah so the thing is I hit this
point where I realized that I was like
what I had the dream I had was to make a
successful company and it was succeeding
I was working with one of my heroes you
know that the team was growing that the
user base was growing we had a product
that people loved but I was feeling that
something was missing like something
like and I was like and that was coming
that was coming at a cost of my personal
productivity that was coming at a cost
of you know like the light like the
satisfaction whatever you want to call
it so I started thing like oh gosh you
know what is it and then I looked like
well what am i doing for fun at night
I'm reading neuroscience papers and I
had this feeling that like I should be
there like that's like that's that's
what's bothering me like I need to be in
it yeah and so we started the phase out
so um along with one of our financing
rounds I started I started phasing out
and this is credit to the people that my
like you write like I was so lucky just
to work with the best people Chuck and
Dan Chuck became the CEO mm-hmm
you know like that I found her leaving
like you just got to call it out like
that is a hard and that can be a very
bad thing yeah right and if they're
moving on to something else they're
really passionate about it you get the
right team filling the spot right and
you do it collaboratively you know so
like when I say this you know like I'm
the product of really great people
investing me like Dan like it was a
phenomenal guy to invest in me and we
might I would say the same thing I think
we all are to a certain extent that the
product of great people investing in us
yeah and then though you give it back
right like hey you know how to do things
like let me invest back in you that's
right so and I think that's the best way
you can show respect to the mentors
right is like show that you can be a
good mentor - yes which is also why like
I think it's important to be really open
about like hey look I'm not perfect I've
screwed up so many times the point is
that's when I started transitioning back
into neuroscience and so this point I'm
27 28 and there was a there was a heroic
neuroscientist named Sebastian Seung and
I had met him all as at IDEO and I
reached out to him I said look like your
work doing deep neural Nets on very very
large scale image data is like I think
the biggest thing in neuroscience I
really want to work with you like what
can I do and he offered me a job to come
work with him out in East Coast so I
moved across sighs this and I started
working the Simons Foundation that's
when we started working on the paper we
were talking about yeah you know that
that pay
was published in sell in 2015
yeah yeah yeah that's huge that's a big
deal to have that have that done and I'm
glad that you made a reach out Sebastian
yeah I strongly suggest if you get the
chance to talk with him yeah Sebastian
song yeah really really magnificent guy
he's a physicist turned into a machine a
computer scientist turned into a
neuroscientist a very very very cool mix
the point of being there and we can talk
about that work cuz it's gonna get him
the idea of complexity in biology yeah
but part of me being there was also like
this is working at the Simons Foundation
was me testing the hypothesis now like
look I know how to program I know how to
do machine learning stuff like just give
me the data like I'm already a
neuroscientist I've read papers before
and that's when I realize like working
at the Simons Foundation being
surrounded by some of the best
neuroscientists in the world then I was
missing something I was finally and when
is the seat of the table people were
talking in a different plane than I was
and I realized like darnit hypothesis
disproven I need to get my PhD and so
specifically what I became really
interested in is the source of new data
because you know this is the Peter
Norvig out of Google saying the idea
that you know the best data is better
than the best algorithms and so with
with the brain and biology we're at this
point now where in combination with the
genetic modification tools and our
ability to understand more and more
organisms and mind more and more
insights out of all these different like
kind of meta genomic data sets we start
getting more tools to get more signal
out of biology and I guess the way I
would describe it like thinking about
biology now is if we're in this building
now like we think like we studied the
complexity of this building with our
eyes right like we and we see that
there's this brick in the wall and
there's a million of these bricks in the
building okay like that's how what the
building is composed of but when you get
all the way down to a single cell you
can't use light anymore you can't say
there's a million bricks and the
membrane of the cell it just doesn't
work but it's like the protein is so
much smaller than the wavelength of
visible light that we don't have
anything to throw at it to bounce back
so what you start doing teams smaller
than a wavelength of visible oh yeah
approach like yeah our visible
wavelength is 500 nanometers
as proteins are like yeah yeah it's like
it's toward is magnitude so you can't
see it yeah but the thing is your cells
are filled with millions of these you
can image in other ways you can image in
other ways but here's the trick you have
to pick a subset of the proteins that
you want to explore that's the like
that's the work we did in 2015 and so
the thing is when you want to visualize
a protein you start with an antibody
right an antibodies taken from your
Munim that can be programmed to bind to
a protein and then once you've got
something that's the you know you've
built that can bind a protein you can
modify that to have some fluorescence so
that's how you can you can visualize
proteins I care about like actin beta
like a part of the cytoskeleton of cells
right so you take an antibody for actin
beta and then it'll stick to every actin
more or less and then you can put it
like a like a fluorescent like a first
and tag on that then you see all of
actin then the question is how many
proteins can you do like that in a
single image if you want to take a
picture of a cell I'll go right to the
punchline it's for more or less it's
four colors that you can resolve out of
a light microscope what why that's it
because the there's a it's part of the
physics of like the way the light
excites moved from these proteins they
they you can only pack so much into the
visible wavelength of light so if you
get them too close together they start
cross bleeding into each other and then
you can't resolve oh we can resolve so
really you're looking at only about four
colors okay and how does that vary
antibody method this is the antibody
method yeah so where we've been to
biology know up to 2014 is like you pick
your four colors you pick your four
bricks that your cell is built out of it
and that's super powerful you know don't
get me wrong like we've made so many
fantastic discoveries there but if you
want to really tell me like how a cell
works from the ground up with four
pieces out of a million knots like it's
limiting totally so do we do how do we
do it this was the paper though that you
were just describing thank you for me
yeah so what we showed in that paper
this was Sebastian Seung and kwanghoon
Chung who's actually in this building
claiming
yeah yeah Casey is amazing yeah thinks
really big and so what Casey had
developed in his lab was the ability to
do multiple realms of this antibody
state so now instead of doing four
different antibody targets for different
proteins you can now do four times you
know for each time there's the
microscope so you do two imaging rounds
you can now see eight proteins okay you
know I think in the paper we showed
twenty or something like that and that's
really big because now you start seeing
a lot more complexity in biology because
20e starts becoming a lot more
discriminative than four yes especially
start talking about the brain like one
of the biggest things that people argue
about in neuroscience is the idea of
cell typing like how many different
types of neurons are there or glia as
well
glia but even just neurons yeah even
just you know just the neuron yeah
people say there's more types of neurons
than any other cell type in the body
well so what are neurons broken down
into what are their subsets yeah well it
depends where in the brain it depends
whether it's an exit or a neuron or an
inhibitory neuron turist installed and
then so then like you have these two
warring factions you've got the lumpers
they just want to like put them all
together and then you got the splitters
who are like actually know like subunits
and yeah we're Texas one and amygdalas
one is that like they actually think
that the cells in the Migdal are
different than the cells in the cortex
that's what yeah well then yes and so
people are doing able to do that from
two different molecular techniques as
one's been evolving also much longer
limbic structures have evolved longer
yeah so we're talking about like
different regions of the brain yeah and
like you know the cerebellum as he's
beautiful like if you look at PNG
neurons they're just these big beefy
like planar neurons with all these big
beautiful spines but but yeah so the
point is we get yeah it's very hard to
they basically have to show not tell all
right like there's a lot we'll have some
nice and beds here as well but yeah
you're yeah because there's been some
gorgeous fight of the the fiber that you
can see the
the neural and a neural architecture to
the mapping that and being able to show
that at least for now
yeah and that will have some embeds here
for to see and then then furthermore as
you're saying all the way down from
where we go up from the spinal column
all the way up to the very tippy top
neocortex is all potentially different
neuron it's yes and then you start
getting like the different parts of each
neuron link then the of like the sub
compartmentalization of that and so the
thing is like yes there's two different
molecular techniques that people been
doing so far to characterize different
cell types and I'm not trying to avoid
going too deep in the cell type world
but it is a good example of where we are
with biological tools so one thing is
you can look at them and when you look
at them generally you do different
antibody stains right hey you know what
like if it's an inhibitory neuron it's
probably expressing gaba so like let's
join antibody against gaba
alright or like and then or if it's
inhibitory that's probably got V gluts
like vesicles for glutamate like it's
gonna be we're gonna do that and sure
enough like give you antibody staying
the - you'll never see those two
crosstalking right so that's one type of
cell type hmm but then there's the other
side where we've made so much progress
thanks to the one like some of the
people you've interviewed with
sequencing right so now sequencing is
very interesting because now we're
starting getting into a type of data
that we can understand we're getting in
the digital data is inhibitory and
excitatory neurons of different
sequences - well they have different
expression patterns yeah Russian so yeah
so this is fun because like I got to
keep in mind that like I haven't for
years deep as a biologist yeah and I'm a
child yeah a lot of other people are
also somewhat children some are really
intelligent so we have a big audience
yeah look when I first started at this
PhD I didn't even know how to use a
pipette yeah for sure so and I think
it's also worth pointing out like the
creative journey that when I first
started I was like look I'm a good
computer programmer like I know how to
do design like I'll figure it out it's
just slightly different you came to the
right place with your background oh of
computers and video lab yeah well
there's an important part of I think my
personal dream which is fun sent to say
is like when I first I went straight to
experiments like whatever like I'm smart
I'll figure it out I did really bad work
for months and I did work that was so
bad I was in the bad track of I knew
what I was doing was bad like low
quality but I did
know how to make it better and the
result of that was I was getting heart
palpitations like I was missing
heartbeats just like I was pipetting
like I don't know why I can't do better
work and then that's what no once again
they come back to mentorship right I got
really lucky and I worked under a
phenomenal postdoc named Johar and I
when I started working on this project
he started giving me the structure of
thinking about biology and thinking
about these challenges and so together
we've been working on this great project
that's several years in the making in
collaboration with George church's lab
and Adam who connectedness and Ed's
group and what we're trying to do is
we're trying to actually see the
sequences in space the sequences see the
sequences in space let me live a space
in space
wait space between nucleotides or space
space means a lot yeah yeah Knossos here
so space inside the original tissue so
okay so okay yeah and so this is fun cuz
like I'm like talking to myself four
years ago yeah you got the structure
from a mentor of how to see biology
Shahar Sahari yeah this is so critical
is that when we get the mentors
multi-year long journey perspective that
can augment our so we don't need to go
through the same treacherous
process of figuring out but we can get
kind of a cheat code in a sense can help
a lot yeah so yeah there's nuance there
too but there's there's so much new ones
because there's there's this time where
it's best to be a student right like
there's times where it's just like ty on
the white belt you're like I trust
everything you tell me and I'm gonna do
it because like you're gonna teach me
how to be better but then after a while
as a student you have to start
developing like I don't believe
everything you tell me I'm gonna start
pushing back that's good and the
question is like you need to figure out
what your optimal like rate of growth is
right and and so for me it's been this
interesting thing where I started being
like screw everybody I'm gonna figure it
out my rate of learning was flat I was
doing nothing and then I like started
working in a great mentor and every time
we got in a technical argument he was
always right and I was like all right
white belt on you know yeah and then we
started working through it and then now
like it's fun to have these
conversations and it's like it's this
like nice peer and I think like all my
my mentors in the past I think like it
grows to that you know it'll always be
that balance of like you're my mentor
[ __ ] you but it's fun to start be able
to push back it's like hey you know what
do we did this and so bass so let's go
into space yeah so the amazing thing
about biology recently is the idea of
complexity is now expanded with the idea
of sequencing so now we're able to get
into a world we understand and I mean by
that is like now we're getting to
digital data we understand the idea of
ACTG right we think about like you know
like when we think about our genome
right we there was sequenced one 2001
and then Barack Obama went on the stage
in 2013 and he had this wonderful status
like for every dollar that went into the
human genome project 140 came out in
terms of startup companies and had like
overall additions to the US economy we
need more things like that it mean was
yeah we need more things like that and
people I think begin to get the idea of
a TCG right like they started getting
okay we were six billion base pairs
three million base pairs and somehow
like that long code makes us who we are
right so let's like let's talk
biologically quickly of like why that
makes us who we are that that genome
that's three billion base pairs six
billion base pairs if you stretched it
out by the way it would be a metre and a
half but somehow that meter and a half
gets coiled all the way into a tiny
little cell that's just five millionths
of a meter big across so first of all
that's a biological miracle
now that whoa yeah okay so we're gonna
wander all over the six billion bases
straight out is a metre and a half and
it can get coiled up in a cell that's
only five microns microns five ten
depending on the it's like if it gets
quoted in the nucleus yeah whoa yeah
okay yes so this is this is how a
biology over the billions of years has
figured out how to become very very
efficient okay continue yeah
so some okay so you've got this ball of
DNA the ball of DNA will selectively
open up when it selectively opens up
that DNA can start being transcribed
into mRNA the mRNA is what that encodes
for proteins and the proteins are the
bricks of the cell they are like your
whole cell is proteins doing things
massively parallel occasionally the
nucleus which
houses the DNA opens and gives a little
messenger RNA to make protein and then
the protein does the further processes
yep catalyze further processes such as
digestion or different types of
processes yeah I mean a protein will do
everything from being structural to
being functional like it'll you know
it'll cut Dean I mean when we say CRISPR
Cass 9 we're talking about Cass 9 being
a protein that cuts DNA so when I put
food in my mouth it's almost as though
my body is going ah it's time to express
for digestion yep that's exactly right
yeah that's exactly right
and people do Studies exact like that
like what's a genetic expression
difference of when like when you're
hungry or you're thirsty versus your
normal yeah that's exactly people do and
so what do people do there is they'll
just take a sample of those cells and
they'll sequence it but they're not
sequencing your DNA they're sequencing
your RNA and so this is where yeah yeah
you know it's it's a very it took me
quite a while to like really grasp this
because I come from the world of thing
about source code mm-hmm right I come
from the world of thing like I wrote
this thing and then it does stuff the
thing is like the TNA is the source code
and by the way like it is a huge like
not faux pas but like it dries
biologists crazy
to speak in these metaphors I'm like oh
it's like like DNA is like the source
code well it's not really but like for
the very very like beginning of getting
used to thinking about it it's helpful
for a bit so if the DNA is the source
code that runs things
it produces copies of itself which are
actually the ones that produce proteins
and so the reason that that's important
is that you can't really tell the like
with exceptions you can't really tell
the difference between the individual
DNA inside a cell but you can see that
what we call the expression profile
difference between cells and so we
talked earlier about like GABAergic or
you know or like inhibitory or exit or
II neurons neurons that do functionally
different things the DNA is the same
they're just behaving differently which
means they're expressing the different
RNA and then so you're trying to
sequence the messenger RNA that's
exactly how do you sequence messenger
RNA aha well so this is what Illumina
did I mean this has been done by many
people for a while but the idea is that
people like they would they would take
them all at like
well the first thing you do is you take
this beautiful piece of biology right
and the first need is you chemically
homogenize it which means you blend it
up and then you flow the DNA or the RNA
that you care about on across this piece
of glass the glass it will functionally
attach to the glass
you will then amplify it so one copy of
the same thing becomes a hundred a
thousand copies and then you can do this
chemistry to make it glow just like
we're talking about with antibodies
earlier you can make it fluoresce and
what's that's a polymerase chain
reaction PCR is a way of amplifying DNA
so it goes from the one mRNA goes from
the one to the some many many copies
your PCR or yeah that's sure yeah that's
where Illumina does it in a different
proprietary no no it's a me you you have
to prepare the you prepare your sample
to go in the aluminum machine okay but
the point is it's able to read it out
base by base by base by base yes yes
okay and so what it looks like is a
bunch of dots it's just a piece of glass
that has like a bunch of little dots
like and then and then you take another
image of it you do some chemistry and
then like that one dot is now arresting
a different color it's now arresting a
different color and then after you do
enough rounds of that you can now
actually piece together what that with
that system what that was like hey you
know like green green green purple green
green red red you know what that's the
actin betta again we found this
transcript and so what we can do is we
can create these molecular profiles of
cells so like how I keep my goal is to
understand the brain we're now like far
down we're talking about Sulton creating
molecular profiles of cells to better
understand exact picture of the exactly
and so what have you been learning with
them molecular profiles of selves well
similarly what have I been learning
personally is that that's the direction
of the that's what I'm yeah that's
that's where I'm getting into is like so
we're not we're not talking about two
different things we're talking about the
complexity in sequence space and then
earlier we were talking about like
viewing things in physical space yeah
yeah and so the goal that I've found to
be really worthwhile is to be able to
combine the two yeah so why have we been
limited for four colors four dimensions
of biology when there's so many more and
so what we're doing in the lab is we're
combining these ideas
we're doing we're capturing the physical
information and we're capturing the
nucleic acid information together and
then we're reading them out so what does
that mean that means we're able to see a
single RNA or started were able to see
like hundreds of RNA different types
inside the space of a single neuron and
then we can start learning from that and
we seem really weird things this is like
one the other thing that's really
interesting is that biology from my
perspective has is is on one hand is
filled with these incredible
experimentalists who go into these very
hard problems with very little tools
like you can see so little out of
biology at first you have to know
exactly how to slice the question
right so when Phil sharp discovered the
intron here at MIT and won the Nobel
Prize for that it blew people's mind to
be like this guy saying hey wait you
know what these mRNAs that people
producing actually have junk DNA that
nobody like that just gets cut out and
is useless and the whole field was like
that's the dumbest thing I've ever heard
why would biology develop this thing to
produce junk that gets cut out and they
have any fought it he proved it you know
in the 80s with very like you know what
we look now is like very primitive tools
and then he won the Nobel Prize for that
so my goal is to take biology to make it
accessible for dummies like me and me
who like maybe I can't design these like
brilliant experiments to like be able to
get these insights with very limiting
tools maybe if we just made the ability
to see this complexity in the sample
itself then we might we might start
getting there
so democratizing the way that we both
view and begin to probe at an abstract
level some of but you've got to know the
micro level then so you have to you have
to understand the micro level and then
be able to run these hypotheses is that
a more macro level to enable more of the
creative potential but that people don't
get some of the micro stuff yeah and the
scale of look I think where you're
touching on is a really important point
it's a scalability of a tool I think if
you get there's a really great idea
which is that if one person can do it
it's an art if a few people can do it
it's a science and then have a lot of
people can do it it's technology well
that's a good way to put it yeah right
so I've done art I've also accidentally
done art right the worst thing you can
do is make something you think is gonna
be scalable and then No
karates what do you think are the best
ways for us to now be developing
technology still understand the
complexities yeah okay so this is the
thing I've now been four years in
biology I can tell you that I feel this
excitement and creativity around the new
technologies in biology like it was
Silicon Valley 78 years ago I do like I
remember having really fun geek outs
when I was there by oh my gosh like we
could use you know aw like Amazon Web
Services just came out like we can use
this and train a big network and then we
can you know solve this and we'll make a
company like people felt that now the
conversations I have here are the same
thing people like wait a second you can
use CRISPR to knock down this transcript
and oh my god you've solved the disease
like that's really and then people just
like start piecing together these
different parts and so if there's one
thing that like is important to get
people excited about is that shift of
biology is now this engineering
substrate not just like a descriptive
thing I shouldn't say really quick like
I took one class in biology two classes
in biology in undergrad the second
lesson I took which was my last one was
ecology where we counted crabs on a
beach and I just left I was like that is
that's that's not my science I don't
care about counting crabs I don't that's
descriptive science I want to be able to
do things with it so your question was
developing the best technologies to help
us understand the complexity of biology
in the brain yeah
so the this is what we want to be able
to build for I want to be able to like
pull a sample out of a meteor and I want
to say I've only got one of these
let's fully describe it and right now we
can't do that we could say okay like we
want to like you know this is of a lien
brain and we can put in an electron
microscope and we can throw electrons at
it rather than photons and electrons can
resolve smaller things and we can
eventually piece together all the little
connections on this brain that's one
thing we can do but then the samples
dead like when you do that you lose in
nucleic acids you lose the proteins or
we can do what people have been doing
which is these antibody stains right and
we can do you know at you 30 proteins
right if this is a really like one of a
kind media or brain maybe we could you
know see 30 proteins you know or we can
grind it up and then we can sequence it
we want to be able to do my goal is to
be able to do it now
like this is shared with people in my
lab and like a lot of people in this
field is we want to be able to do all of
those in one sample yeah and so to do
that you need this highly multiplexed
RNA readout and the reason is is that
people have not solved how to do the the
protein readout like highly multiplexed
yet so we can't do that but we can read
out nucleic acids so what we do the
complex protein that those are some very
good people working on that that is like
so protein sequencing is a huge open
challenge interesting that is very much
a Holy Grail that's very hard to do yeah
but also like the thing is like from my
perspective like I've done hard things
that people didn't care about you know I
think people will care about RNA
sequencing in context of like the
original tissue and if we can do it in a
scalable way then like I think that's
what I'm laser focused on right now
interesting okay RNA sequencing in the
actual tissue yeah and the space in the
space yeah so how do we preserve space
well like what we do in our lab is we
can anchor everything in a gel so this
is like this is one of the things the
hydrogel this is this mobile hydrogel
swellable hydrogels yeah expansion my
cross expansion microscopy yeah it's
like the stuff that's in diapers
exactly right you've done your research
yeah yeah and so first of all they
admire that original work because when I
ate that had just come out when I joined
the lab and also I could say like
sub-problem of a sub-problem
i didn't get it I was like why I don't
care like I want to I want to solve the
brain why are you making things like
gels that expand well it turns out that
one of the problems is the limitations
of light but also like having a scaffold
to explore biology with like in this
case it is a physical scaffold it
anchors all the molecules you care about
you can pull them apart and then you can
do whatever you want with them and turns
out like that idea which is like kind of
esoteric to the outside world is both
super scalable because it's diapered
polymer and it costs nothing to do but
then also like you you can do additional
chemistry's on that intact sample so
whereas like people have formulaic
formula if you wanted to read out lots
of different RNA you have to flow them a
costly glass cell
now we can actually preserve the whole
thing in the original context so instead
of grinding up that brain you can now
look at the brain and you can see
hundreds thousands of different RNA
molecules so you're adding an expansion
microscopy polymer to the space between
the tissue yeah and then you and then a
and then you're able to make it easier
for yourself to go in and do the
antibody binding enabling you to the
sequence be more easily the proteins and
mRNA yeah and I should say like you know
like sequencing means a lot of different
things the point the point is that you
can we use the word multiplex which is
like a very fancy way of saying read out
lots of multiplex multiplex is what we
say for the duplex that's like kind of
like a that could be lady multi-omics as
well like you're trying to do a
multiplex readout yeah which means
sequencing yeah oh sequencing capture
protein you know like RNA yeah so
there's there's there's a few major
classes of biological Pro like molecules
right you grab though the nucleic acids
you have the proteins you have the
sugars lipids all right interesting okay
so in the perfect world you see all of
them at once right like that's if you
want talk about like multi-omics like
get all the biomolecules but turns out
that's hard right and so like you know
then I think but if you want to take
that meteor brain and you want to
understand it completely you do need to
be able to see all molecules and at
least the first thing you can do is you
can start by preserving them and then
eventually you know like if they're all
physically in this thing you can you can
get the information out some wrapping
thoughts are what about then other
technologies that you are just roaring
with your imagination but that are
really hard to like ground and actually
implement but what are what is the field
thinking that's wildest imagination
could help well I think about two things
on that I think first of all like a big
part of my background is design like
scalable consumer products right and
then deep science I think I guess
whatever you call this thank you
doing a PhD in neurobiology tool
building for neurobiology the thing is
the way science is done and communicated
has a lot of room for growth and
specifically the funding side of it is
very interesting and so the one thing I
have a particular interest in as well is
like how can we start rethinking right
can we start redesigning the structure
of scientific funding and that's like so
this is like same thing I'm asking I'm
answering this in the context of like if
you could design a new technology I'm
framing this is like if I could design
any system that's a great point I would
like really want to explore this and I
think there's I think there's
interesting ideas and there's really
like good opportunities but that's like
that's one thing I think about yeah
shout out to the brain mind ecosystem
grandma yeah brain - mind org I mean
they're really rethinking financing for
the very great job yeah the systems of
neuroscientist philanthropists all that
type of stuff so yeah did okay
interesting so that's the first one was
the second thought yeah so the other
thing I would think about is okay it's
gonna sound jargony so we're gonna
unpack it is non monolithic artificial
intelligence yes to teach us okay so I'm
now at the point where like when people
talk a I blah blah blah like for me that
the discussions over like it may not be
exactly what we imagined for the movies
but it's gonna here it's gonna hit
that's my that's my floss yeah totally I
think it already happens like this is
like you know and we see it everywhere
we see like we see it in the successive
ads like that's kind of why like I come
back to that like there's a lot of money
being poured in that they're those ads
work for a reason because those things
are perfectly targeted how are they
perfectly targeted they perfectly
understand you yeah there's a reason
that Facebook spent nineteen billion
dollars targeting whatsapp to buy what's
up do you know why it's like because you
now have this enormous corpus of
conversation talk or you know human
conversations a couple gigantic papers
have come out in the past three years
that like to me like I left the lecture
being like oh my god
like this is why am I like Facebook
bought whatsapp one is something called
once again jargony deep learning on
non-euclidean data by Bronstein and
and the non-euclidean meaning graph
structures graph structures yes so what
we do when we process image data is we
learn these filters on these filters are
just bunch of linear operations done on
what you called Euclidean data Euclidean
just means there's some distance
function so like difference train these
two pixels Euclidean when you talk about
graphs that didn't really like there's
not really like that distance function
metric these people solved it
y'all McCune runs Facebook AI research
right so the thing is you know what else
goes like in graph our conversation aha
like everything back and forth you and I
have like it can go in three or four
different directions you and I are just
choosing different paths you throughout
this graph the tree of possibility so
when I think about like these AI things
and what they're scary about I'll talk
about the other deep learning paper that
blew my mind but when I think about the
the AI and the things that are gonna
come from it like it's gonna happen like
and it's gonna lease happen a resolution
that's good them a lot of people are
gonna be able to tell the difference so
if you know what's gonna happen how do
you react to it you react to it one way
realizing that very few people are gonna
be able to replicate it great example
Amazon go store I don't have you ever
been there in Seattle nobody else but
Amazon has that image processing
capability right there are a couple
others that do now we have a standard
cognition office that's right in our
office in San Francisco where are these
videos and they're doing it at a pretty
close level right now and it's good and
there's apparently some competitors as
well not only in the United States and
even in San Francisco and stuff but also
China as well so but anyway yes yes so
the idea of the non monolithic AI is
need to start finding ways that you
don't need to have a warehouse full of
computers to replicate that same
performance interesting so you're that
you're talking about replicating
performance with non warehouse full of
the data so in this case a monolith is
the Amazon Web Services Club the Google
Cloud the Facebook like will process
every conference yeah not monolithic
what does that mean what means lower
power lower power yet right it means
something that you don't need these like
you get a lot of this AI stuff that's
been done in in many ways and I think
it's I'm saying this out of respect it's
brute force and now the deep mind work
is incredible so late but the thing is
like if you look send a computation
through potentially with the power of
something like a quantum computer just
hypothetically yeah through a swath of
data and then be able to come out so
something really small could give you
something really profound through a
couple petabytes or whatever of data
yeah yeah a couple petabyte I think well
so humans are amazing because we can
learn from pretty much no data oh yeah
well don't we get a lot of data we get a
lot of data in but the thing is like you
get bit by one alligator you're gonna
stay away from alligators the rest of
your life like on the current like
state-of-the-art neural networks they
need to get bitten by a lot of
alligators that's an interesting one so
and you look at this like art our brain
puts out you requires the same amount of
power as your the lamp in your
refrigerator it's just a few watts
whereas like the power that it took to
beat Lisa doll and alphago right was
thousands like that most Florida's
magnitude so if you scale this up you
think that like very few people can
replicate a Google Facebook so to me one
of the most motivating things also about
really understanding the brain is to
start thinking about like how more
people could have access to that kind of
computational power because this is this
is the punchline
I think it's gonna happen yeah the
question is like is it gonna be in the
hands of a few or is it going to be in
the hands if anyone can get here like
get their hands on we agree we've had
lots of conversations about the
substrate monopolies and the way to
potentially put it in the hands of the
many and democratize it for maximal
creative computational purposes yes I'm
this is a whole nother conversation we
we do this the Bay Area visit next time
to the recording studio or the next time
in Cambridge Dan we're gonna have you
back on we got to keep unpacking it's
also just as an interlocutor just a
little thought for you is that this has
been one of my favorite conversations
trying to put the recency bias aside
this is just because I love your energy
I love the way your cadence I love the
way that you make really profound
connections across fields and you make
it relatable your analogies and
metaphors and stories are what really
helps people get
easier so huge shout out to you this has
been such a pleasure thank you for
coming dude likewise brother yes we
quickly do you think we're in a
simulation ha no okay and then what do
you think the most beautiful thing in
the world my wife all right all right
this has been so so so fun and we'll get
to unpack those answers on the next time
we do the show huge thank you everyone
for tuning and we greatly appreciate
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you think about developing the
technologies to capture the complexity
of biology in the brain share with your
friends your families your co-workers
online of social media get talking about
it get inspiring and engaging more
people to build the future check out
Dan's links below
also check out simulations links below
support the artists and entrepreneurs
and organizations across the world that
you believe in and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world thank you so much for
tuning in and we will see you soon peace
brother that was fire good hustle good
hustle